foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar scmos
cameras for light sheet microscopy I am
Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Teledyne photometrics to learn more
visit photometrics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Professor
Ulrich kubichek professor of biophysical
Chemistry University of Bonn Dr Abhishek
Kumar Marine biological laboratory
investigator in Chan Zuckerberg
initiative Imaging scientist
Matthew Coast Dunn content manager
Teledyne photometrics and Phil Allen
product manager Teledyne photometrics
Professor kubichek Dr Kumar Matthew and
Phil you may now begin your presentation
and welcome to another teledive
photometrics webinar
this webinar is going to be all about
light sheet microscopy the benefits
the challenges and how such a variable
application is light sheet microscopy
can have all its needs met by modern
CMOS camera Technologies
a little introduction to us here at
telephone photometrics we design and
manufacture these high-end cameras for
biological and life science Imaging this
helps us to support demanding
quantitative research with these Imaging
devices that allow you to have very high
image quality but retain all the
information in your data this is mostly
scientific CMOS Technologies
some of you may know us as photometrics
since 2019 it's been television 30
metrics as we were established as part
of the talent Imaging
this webinar today involves myself Dr
Matthew Kaze Dunn I work at Teledyne
photometrics as an application
specialist
we're also going to involve Dr Phil
Allen who is our product marketing
manager who's going to talk to you later
on about some of our product lines that
are very suitable for light sheet
but the main focus here is our guest
speakers who are both experts in the
field of light sheet microscopy
firstly with Professor Uric kabitz check
at the University of Bonn
and Dr Abhishek Kumar at the Marine
biological laboratory in woodsol and
we'll hear from them both later on
firstly an outline of light sheet
microscopy
the concept here is to minimize photo
damage and bleaching if your sample is
exposed to very high intensities of
light over the long term it can cause a
lot of negative effects
like she also avoids out of focus light
often seen in wide field techniques it
can optically section 3D specimens
which is seen also in confocal
Technologies
this allows you to freely image large 3D
specimens
you can also do this at very high speeds
so you can observe very fast Dynamic
events and you can image them over the
long term thanks to the minimized photo
damage and due to the open nature of
light sheet there are many different
variants that exist and can be modified
specifically for your Imaging needs
so as an overview
you can call these techniques light
sheet fluorescence microscopy or lsfm
these diagrams here show you how the
illumination and detection is different
for these different techniques
if we look at wide field you can see
that the entire sample in your field of
view is bathed in light the field is
very wide
everything you're looking at is being
illuminated and this can cause damage
and bleaching it also means you're
getting fluorescence emission back from
samples that you're not focusing on
outside the focal plane seen here by the
horizontal blue line
this means you get out of focus light
and all kinds of artifacts
the alternative is confocal we're using
pinholes this works to eliminate out of
focus light but with techniques like
laser scanning confocal it's a very high
intensity laser dot that can damage your
sample and with techniques like spinning
disc on focal you also have to make sure
that your disk speed can match up with
the speed you want to image and there's
a number of different things to take
into account in Spinning Disk microscopy
can be very technically challenging
one of the Alternatives that's come up
is light sheet microscopy as you can see
here the illumination and detection are
now occurring at 90 degrees to each
other
the illumination comes in from the side
as almost in this case an hourglass
shaped light sheet at the thinnest part
of The Hourglass this is where it's
intersecting with your fluorophores in
the sample and it's only across
the focal plane
this is how it can eliminate out of
focus lights and this is how you can
also maintain illumination on just a
single plane and this allows you to also
minimize the photo damage so by
decoupling the illumination and
detection in this manner as seen in the
diagram light sheet microscopy offers
the ability to still image these large
samples but with less light dose
so you illuminate a thin plane of the
sample you get minimized photo damage
Optical sectioning you eliminate the
out-of-focus lights and some of these
techniques can also be faster than laser
scanning confocal which allows you to
image more Dynamic events
this is also known as spin or selective
plane illumination microscopy the point
here is that
this is the most basic form of light
sheet microscopy and there are many
different variants of spin the
objectives can be in all sorts of
different places you may require
multiple illumination or detection
objectives this is the basic format that
has evolved over the years to meet
different needs in imaging
here are some popular light sheet
systems
for all of these the illumination
objective is in blue and the detection
objective is in green with our sample
being the black circle
we have spam we also have t spin
teaspoon essentially means you're
Illuminating from both sides of the
sample this can eliminate Shadows that
may form if you're just Imaging from one
side
yourself mspim where you take this
concept further and have multiple
detection objectives
and then you have different ways of
positioning the objectives in order to
image different samples and allow
yourself to have different sample
geometries you have oblique spam
tilted light sheet reflective light
sheet and you also have inverted
and dual view inverted spin where
essentially you can now have the sample
on a surface and you have the objectives
at a specific angle so you can flip the
whole thing upside down these different
configurations can match the different
experiments you're trying to do
something that's common between most of
these is that you do have a restricted
choice in terms of the objectives that
you can use
and the space that your sample can
occupy
if you want to use a very high n a oil
objective you may not find it compatible
with some of these techniques and if you
want to image a very large cleared
sample it also may not be compatible
with some of these techniques
so while there are a lot of variants
there are some shared restrictions
a recent development in light sheep
technology is single objective light
sheet
by having one objective doing both the
illumination and the detection
this allows you to take off the
restrictions on your objectives now you
can use oil objectives you can get
higher numerical aperture you can get
higher resolution you can also have
different shapes and environments of
samples you can have these things inside
closed atmospheres so your cells Can Be
Live While You're Imaging them and you
can add additional modular Hardware to
them this is so spin where you reflect
the light sheet off a surface and with
the same objective detect the emitted
fluorescence this is used in
microfluidics installed into lab on a
chip systems these allow for very high
throughput systems that you can add flow
to
you also have a bleak plane microscopy
where you can simply shoot out your
light sheet at an angle and collect the
emitter's fluorescence from the sample
this is developed in several directions
and light sheet is a actively constantly
developing area so there are always more
of these coming out some of the examples
that are developed from oblique play
microscopy include scape from Elizabeth
Hillman which is swept confocally
aligned plane excitation
and the snout scope from the Andrew York
club
there's all kinds of different
techniques and developments coming out
so light sheets are very exciting and
active area
these all allow you to push your field
of view speed and resolution of your
Technique as far as you can go once you
pair it with a suitable camera so
depending on what your experiment needs
there's often a light sheet technique
that's suitable for you
but you don't have to take my word from
it let's speak to our experts and see
what kind of light sheets they use what
their opinions are about it
where they think the field is going to
go in the future and what kind of
cameras they use on their systems
my name is
I'm a professor for biophysical
chemistry here at the University of Bonn
I'm located in the Department of
Chemistry so the general area is
chemistry although from my education I'm
a physicist and
so since I do science I also do
microscopy and and that's what really
directs me to to do and what really
fascinates me since decades now
I did I think meanwhile all almost all
available types of microscopy starting
out as plain influorescence microscopy
then going over to confocal microscopy
to Photon microscopy
photo bleaching techniques and then I
stepped into a single molecule Imaging
and then more and more we noted that
very often you need specific microscopes
to answer specific biological questions
and that's where I am now and what we do
now preferentially
Imaging scientist at the Marine
biological laboratory in Woods Hall and
by training I am a physicist but I'm
here at MBL to develop microscopy tools
and worked with biologists to push that
envelope basically to understand what
are the limitations of existing tools
and Technologies and basically see where
we can play a role or what we can do to
develop new tools which will help
biologies to do
address their biological problems so
that's my research interest so basically
in a nutshell
you can tell that we are trying to
combine
Hardware or Optical engineering software
part from computer vision to data
analysis to Control software and apply
these two together to address some
biological problems so I feel fortunate
that I am at the MBL because
whatever we are developing there is
immediate application of those tools but
more than that we are in a unique
position where our commercial Partners
our researchers
at different universities and various
places whatever new tools or technology
they are developing they are willing to
bring it here so we being at the MBL get
access to all this latest and greatest
Technologies uh early on and that's very
enriching personally because I get to
learn about new tools and technology and
also I get to see which direction
overall the scientific Community is
going as far as new
developments uh are concerned
yeah we we got into like microscopy by
using the cylindrical way of
Illuminating a sample because we noted
it's simply an excellent way how to
reduce background and be used there to
perform single molecule Imaging in
extended samples that's great to have
really a low background but also
simultaneously a fast camera data
acquisition which is
for example not possible to achieve this
convocal microscopy but then things
developed on their own somehow yeah so
we we did some applications with that
and uh pretty successful uh examining uh
for example nuclear cytoplasmic
transport using that technique
but then I was contacted by people in
from the Neuroscience Department here in
Born which was pretty big and well known
and very productive because people noted
that large microscopy is an excellent
technique for studying brain structure
Mouse by instructor model in model
systems and so yeah just for for the fun
of it we we began to work with them and
okay we found out they want to look at
really big samples they are extended
samples
that this I have a very I have a
solution simultaneously and obviously
that's a contradiction and so I mean to
to buy a microscope is was not the best
option then and so in a very close
connection with them we started to
develop the microscopes they meet and
that perform for for the task optimally
So like um all of us I mean we are
excited about
um a light sheet because I mean
certainly it's a very gentle technique
for optical Imaging and it also offers a
fast speed because we want uh to capture
uh live
um things uh fast Dynamics so it has all
these potentials and that's why we are
all excited about this technology
so but just to give you because we are
interested in doing live Imaging so we
want to be as gentle as possible so that
we don't perturb the
biology or the developmental phenomena
we want to capture so so it's a
it's it's it's very sample dependent and
biology dependent but we try to be as
gentle as possible so that without
perturbing that phenomena we can capture
long-term uh lives clearly we are using
our lightsit microscopes to do live
Imaging so like live cells uh live
embryos basically we want to start at
very early stages like um when they
fertilize and watch in their development
or capture their developmental process
it's all live I mean we have looked at
all kinds of starting from C elegans
shrimp I mean shrimp embryo uh squid
embryo fly fish so uh Axolotl so we have
looked at all kinds of organisms
right I mean I mean that's again uh as I
told you that's a benefit of being at
the MBL is people bring Hydra all kinds
of creatures whatever they can capture
on our Stony Beach they will bring it to
our lab and say okay can we image on a
light sheet
the Workhorse
still is a very normal gaussian
elimination that we scan so a digitally
scanned nitrate microscope
and uh because these are so easy to to
build and to produce I think meanwhile
we we built four or five or even six of
them I I don't remember
but for the application of studying
brain structure over a large field then
we started also trying out different uh
illumination modes like vessel
illumination and the The Vessel grating
illumination that was introduced by Eric
betsek so we we built that and uh tried
that and currently we we are really
working rather on Airy beam illumination
and so this is one of the ongoing
projects where we have an area beam
illumination but uh as you might know
edible elimination uh also has involved
with producing side lobes for the
illumination and this creates artifacts
background artifacts and we develop
currently new techniques how to get rid
of this background but also we we have
one instrument uh that we constructed
using two Photon excitation and this is
used for a lively buff fish the
development of the neural system of
deeper fish
that is done over several
days yeah so for a really long periods
of time that is a normal scan to vote on
life sheet that also involves a vessel
illumination because for True Photon
excitation this is especially
preferential
by now there are 50 different variant
Supply sheet um
and as you know there are probably about
10 12 commercial products in the market
so my lab I mean because I have a
history when I was a postdoc with Dr
Harish RAF and at the NIH and Dr Daniel
colon Ramos at Yale University I got
involved with dice them
dual view inverted selective plane
illumination microscope so still We are
continuing that we are trying to add a
small small uh
capabilities or component to that die
spam so I have a dice Pim and my lab is
also developing a second generation or
third generation whatever you want to
call of a dice beam to look at large and
extended samples
so basically we are trying to uh do some
small modifications so that will allow
us to basically image a large samples so
that's one component I am also
interested if you follow literature
there are a lot
more work and developments been done in
single view like sheet microscopy uh
specifically
um
uh work follow-up work from Dr Elizabeth
Hillman's grew and Dr densby's group
Andrew York at Calico retofalk
[Music]
in Texas and Lloyd at CGI so they are
kind of expanded uh uh this design to
capture slightly higher numerical
aperture and that's very promising
because it allows us to use the
conventional sample mounting at the same
time we can have access to a large
numerical aperture for high resolution
imaging so that's another aspect I am
very much interested in
uh so that's the second aspect in my lab
where we are interested in single view
light sheet microscope uh and the third
aspect is do to do multi-view there are
many because at the MBL we have to deal
with uh large embryos or large samples
like squid and all so for that uh doing
multi-view uh two-sided illumination and
two-sided detection that um
configuration is also appropriate for
what we are doing so in my lab we are
building a variant of that microscope as
well so I would say there are three
different uh
likes it microscopes uh what we are
interested in because there is no
Universal microscope which works for all
kinds of samples so it all depends any
microscope is good or bad it depends on
our biological problem and kind of
sample we would like to image so that's
why we have a different systems for
different applications
according to my view currently still the
largest problem is that of the center
preparation and
basic men fixation in the microscope
also another point is that many nitrate
microscopes do not
provides a possibility to easily change
the objects
the illumination or the detection Optics
illumination may not be so so critical
because you can regulate the
illumination relatively easily by using
as I said bezel beams or ratings of
vessel beams or
Airy beams and so on so you have a lot
of options uh on that side but for the
detection this this is a major problem
or many microscope types do not allow to
change
from 4X to 10x to 40x detection back
yeah so this this is really something
that that is important to do on the fly
so I think this also needs in for some
companies uh development work
and of course the next big thing is the
data which still is really a major
problem currently yeah so I mean the the
always in continuously we invest in more
and greater data storages and faster
transfer and and go for search for
Solutions on that side
so in my opinion there are two major
challenges one is uh the most important
one is data handling a lot of times we
can collect data but we suddenly feel
that we are not ready to uh extract
meaningful information from that pile of
data that's certainly one of the
challenges uh and which it's not me I
mean I think people in this community we
are all facing this challenge together
uh
uh the associated challenges once you
have a multi-view Imaging we need to
fuse them together in a smart way so
that we can get uh
uh best out of all views and that's also
that depends on image quality and all
and if you want to have a very automated
uh process uh sometimes uh it requires
slightly higher quality images or it's a
little tricky
so I think that that's that's one
challenge the other challenge I would
say is a lot of times people get excited
that oh we have a fancy light sheet can
I image that but sample mounting is also
a challenge
depending on what configuration what
type of light sheet you have the sample
mounting requirements are different
so again it's not like a confocal where
you somehow put your sample between
cover slips and you can mount on any
current focal here it depends what
configuration light chip system you have
and according accordingly you have to
tailor your sample mounting so in many
cases when we work with new samples or
new organisms we end up spending a lot
of time figuring out or optimizing the
sample mounting which is very specific
to the configuration of a light shift
system we are using so I feel that
that's another challenge as a community
we need to work together and share
uh nodes or exchange notes with each
other so that we can learn from each
other and make progress
so we have a limited choice of lenses
you can use in most of these live sheet
configurations so in many cases we are
using uh if you are convinced no light
sheet approach we are using water
dipping lenses so there your sample
mounting is different and also sample
mounting like if you are aware of
flamingo system or other systems there
you can
you need to embed your sample in a
capillary and aggroes and all but if you
want to do cell biology you can't do
like that so there are lattice light
sheet or dice beam or
Os theme or this kind of a single
objective steam where you put your
samples on a cover slip and you image on
that is more Well Suited I would say
yeah what are our limitations so
conventional light sheet microscopes we
use a gaussian beam so if I extend my
field of view my beam is going to
diverge more so what we do is we use low
in a beam so and we don't focus it
tightly so that it's not converging and
diverging very fast
so you extend your kind of depth in that
respect but you sacrifice your light
shift thickness
so it's a kind of trade-off
uh so that's one limitation
um but there are some other work around
where
um uh latest group and some other groups
they have demonstrated that you can
focus it tightly and you do axial scan
you can do axial scan fast and there are
these light sheet modes on these CMOS
cameras are handy because when you are
doing actual scan you can sync the
rolling shutter readout with that beam
waste uh to get but again you are
limited how far you can scan that in
axial Dimension or along the optic axis
of your lens
uh so I think that's a major bottleneck
uh for us because if we extend the field
of view suddenly what you realize is
part of your sample is seeing thin light
sheet but other part of your sample is
looking at very thick lights
so image quality across this plane is
not uniform or not similar as similar as
we would like so that's one of the
challenge if you sacrifice magnification
and numerical aperture you can use low n
a lenses and there you can make a
thicker light seat and extend your field
of view
like else by type of system where they
are looking at
millimeters or centimeter large samples
but they make 20 Micron uh thick light
sheet and extend the field of view but
if I want to do cell biology then the 20
Micron is a White Field it's not a light
sheet anymore so it's a kind of relative
term depending on what type of samples
we are looking at what length scale what
sort of lens or numerical aperture we
are using for illumination hand
detection and based on that I mean this
field of view is I mean governed by that
in my opinion what we are going to soon
encounter is even we can go much faster
let's suppose I can go three times or
five times faster but we need enough
photons
to capture in that sort I mean time so
the other thing we also need is a bright
probes and that's what some other
companies and other labs like a company
like promega they are trying to develop
these bright probes so that even we can
go faster we will have enough signal to
capture so I think it's all going hand
in hand
um
like speed large area
High sensitivity but at the same time we
need those bright probes so that we can
get enough signal in that uh fast
acquisition mode
first detection system that is capable
of really low light level Imaging
because I mean photons are always always
limited whatever labeling technique you
use yeah and secondly in most
applications at least that we really
require a large period of use
and of course then canvas are optimal
that have a large sense or and are very
sensitive so this combination is that
what what we use most often what we use
are scientific CMOS cameras uh this is a
standard now since since many years we
started out with back illuminated emccbs
but we switched to the CMOS because
um they have we started out using them
because they they provide this light
sheet modes that we explored in one of
our Publications on confocal light sheet
microscopy then we use the fact that you
can really
shift the read out region of the camera
across the chip during illumination and
you can create a a line scanning
confocal microscope by by that way
in in a very very simple and
straightforward manner what provides you
with a improved contrast for Imaging and
reduces background
and if you look at large samples your
illumination beam always has to be
pretty extended thick yeah in in all
directions so the account is always an
issue in that case yeah now we will
rather go for CMOS commas because of
their chip size yeah and also the the
small size of the of the pixels yeah
they have these 6.45 micrometer size
pixels and then they provide extremely
large uh fields of view and of course
that is optimal if you want to look at
at large regions of a sample
and this is also by the way the reason
why we do experiments with air and b
illumination because that provides a
very long and uh very constant
illumination field on the camera side I
must say so for the detection side I'm
pretty happy by now yeah because the
current CMOS cameras they provide
Quantum efficiencies that are really
close to one I mean this is fantastic
yeah and they really have the low noise
so a lot of progress has been done on
that side and I'm really really happy
about that also the big sensors as I
already said
yeah I mean especially kinetics is that
camera that we need for this kind of
applications and we found that we can
reduce the number of frames considerably
that that we need to cover a large field
of view and that is simply due to the
large sense law and to our
supplies and uh yeah
the microscope Optics is also capable of
Illuminating the the large sensor in a
very good manner so I think the the
field number of the objective lens is
something like 25 in that that we use in
that case but still we were able really
to to get a very excellent image over
the complete sensor of all the kinetics
camera so that put used no problem as we
might have uh thought before
so here I'm going to speak for myself
and my lab I mean we use uh thanks to
photo metrics for your likeship
initiative that's a that's a very good
initiative in my opinion and I'm honored
to be part of that so ideally what we
want we want High Quantum efficiency so
that we can detect low life we want fast
speed as possible and we want as big
chip as possible so all three
and that's what um uh all I mean camera
companies they are going in that
direction like your um 95b I mean that
that's a very good camera for us because
it has a large chip
fast frame rate and also very high
Quantum efficiency
camera is leading in a way because I
mean once you guys make this progress
and you say that okay now we can go
faster then other Hardware aspects we
are trying to follow that okay now we
can go faster let's keep up with that so
in a way camera technology is also
leading uh the development of light
sheet
thanks again to our guests Professor
Orica Beach and Dr Abhishek Kumar now
we're going to hand over to my colleague
Dr Phil Allen who's going to take us
through some product lines that are
suitable for light sheet Imaging over to
you Phil
hello all I'm Phil Allen product manager
for Teledyne photometrics I'll be
introducing you to several of our
cameras today that are particularly
appropriate for light sheet Imaging
as our speakers have told you
as Matt has introduced you
light seat microscopy is an expanding
collection of techniques that demand the
most of your sample and the optical and
electronic systems involved with the
goal of providing you with useful
insight about your biology
whether it's single plane dual plane
single objective scanning pencil beam
oblique illumination Escape axially
scanned light sheet or some other light
sheet method Teledyne photometrics was a
camera to get you the results you want
cameras for light sheet really need to
do it all with the diversity of
approaches being used cameras need to be
highly flexible to meet the needs of
your of the science you're all doing
cameras need to be sensitive with low
noise High Quantum efficiency to capture
all the photons coming back from the
sample and turn them into a useful
result
cameras have to have the speed to keep
up with the events researchers want to
capture with their electric systems
Imaging neuronal activity in a zebrafish
or Mouse brain mapping protein
localization and fixed and expanded
organs require High frame rates high
speeds and high pixel throughput
some light sheet methods can take
advantage of digital split confocal
approaches where the output of the
camera is matched to the position of the
illumination line to enhance contrast
all the cameras presented today utilize
our programmable scan mode to enhance
axial Focus or swept pencil beam sheet
regeneration
I'm going to talk to you about three
specific product families the kinetics
family the BSI family and the iris 15.
um you may have heard of various or used
various of these products the kinetics
is our newest best and we'll talk delve
into what we why we're so excited by it
it now has two variants the inter the
originally introduced 29 millimeter
diagonal field of view and a new 22
millimeter diagonal field of view and it
really provides you with the ultimate
flexibility for your light key damaging
systems the BSI and the BSI Express are
our classic c-mount cameras 18
millimeter diagonal fields of view
relatively fast up to frame rates of 100
frames per second
and then the iris the irises are a
classic example of a smaller pixel
camera designed for lower magnification
lower in a sampling often used for large
samples like in mesospim so these are
some of the details of the camera
families the kinetics family and the BSI
family both use kind of industry
standard six and a half Micron pixels
obviously they have different array
sizes of the pixels both of them are
back illuminated cameras so they are 95
Quantum efficiency at their Peak I'll
talk more about the camera modes in a
second and again the iris 15 goes up to
5K by 3K sensor array with 4.25 Micron
pixels these sensors collect different
amounts of the field of view that your
Optical system could put out
nicely Illustrated here with a series of
colored boxes
the kinetics is got the largest field of
view of any scientific camera out there
3200 by 3200 six and a half Micron
pixels for a 29 millimeter diagonal
across the Box
the kinetics is a camera we've designed
to maximize throughput throughput comes
with two aspects how much data can you
collect from your system and how fast
can you collect that data
um so the Kinex samples
all the field of view your Imaging
system could put together
um if you compare it to the prime BSI or
the iris it speaks for itself more than
2.5 times greater area than the classic
BSI area
it's a 10 megapixel sensor one-to-one
format industry standard six and a half
Micron pixels kinetics 22 is a new
member of the kinetics family which will
collect the maximum area that a c-mount
can put out but the most important part
to me as a product manager and you as a
scientist is flexibility
how many problems can this device solve
and I think kinetics is the has the most
flexibility of any scientific camera out
there and that kind of relates to these
four Imaging modes dynamic range
capturing bright to dim signals in the
same frame sensitivity low noise at
moderate moderately good frame rates
speed no one else can do 500 just shy of
500 frames per second at the full array
of the sensor that data comes out at
five gigabytes per second when you image
the full frame of the kinetics
so ideal for Imaging fast processes like
voltage sensors or calcium transients
the kinetics now has a new subelectron
mode with a 0.7 electron read noise this
is the lowest noise mode in our camera
line and because of the way we've
actually used the conversion gain it has
emccd like contrast very low signals
from your sample can can give you very
contrasty measurable images
so a quick summary this is the kinetics
High sensitivity high speed high Quantum
efficiency large numbers of pixels with
high throughputs the kinetics 22 real
quickly all that but slightly smaller
field of view for the folks who can't
take advantage of the 29 millimeter
diagonal field of view of the full
kinetics so it comes up at 2400 by 2400
6.5 Micron pixels if your Imaging system
doesn't cover why collect data that you
don't need has a total of 5.7 megapixels
same modes as the kinetics and same
frame rates as the kinetics BSI and the
BSI Express kind of classic cameras they
also contain our programmable scan mode
which are very appropriate for many
light sheet uses 2048 by 2048 6 Micron
pixels back illuminated has a one
electron read noise mode at 40 frames a
second can do up to a kilohertz for
those watching Fast frame rates but only
at a limited number above just under 200
rows the Iris camera is being used a lot
in light sheet particularly for things
like mesospim classic spim with lower
magnification and lower numerical
aperture Imaging systems so because
there's a 4.25 Micron pixel there are
two variants the 15 megapixel and the 9
megapixel so just about 5000 by 3000 in
the in the five megapixel and 3K by 3K
uh in the nine it comes with both pcie
or USB interfaces unlike our other two
cameras which come with both interfaces
so I've mentioned programmable scan mode
this is a digital approach where you
match the readout of the lines of the
sensor from in the camera to where your
illumination band is we and others find
this as a useful way of collecting the
tightly focused illumination beam while
discarding a scattered light that might
fall outside the illumination slit so if
you're using actually scanned light
sheet from Red opioca's lab or a
scanning pencil beam or scanning to
Photon or vessel beam to actually create
your sheet programmable scan mode is
very helpful to throw away that out of
focus scattered light so there's two
ways to control it in our software you
can actually input the delay you want to
create a number of lines that would be
integrated or you can actually just say
I want so many lines they both
effectively delay the readout of the
sensor so that you get a band of
collection versus a full frame of
collection that rolls down the sensor as
your focused Regan or your pencil beam
scans the sample
so there's three directional controls
um down up and highlighted here down up
which is actually quite useful for those
of you using galvos and I'll explain
that in a second
so with down the Illumination in blue is
is scanning the sample the the emission
light is being rescanned onto the sensor
and then as you can see the point of the
triangle gets illuminated first and
arrives first at the camera in the next
scan same thing different scan indicated
in different color but we're basically
scanning top to bottom in download not
surprised only the camera app puts top
to bottom
similarly in up mode we're going to tell
the sensor to read from the bottom of
the sensor and go up so the base of the
triangle arrives first the point arrives
last and what the camera outputs is as
you would expect
no one else has implemented down up mode
and the benefit here is there's no
flyback time in this galvo we've got
here because we're going to scan down
and then up and then down and up so what
it's going to actually arrive at the
sensor from your image are a series of
inverted images but the camera knows
what it's doing here so what the actual
camera is going to Output is going to
flip every other image so that you don't
have to do that after the fact thank you
for your time
have a good day
thanks again to Phil for taking us
through the kinetics Prime BSI and Iris
families of CMOS cameras for light sheet
microscopy to follow up on this we have
some real life examples of the kinetics
and Iris cameras being used for light
sheet microscopy
our first customer story is also from
Professor kabitzkek this application
concerns super resolution expansion
light sheet where essentially samples
are physically magnified via expansion
and then you can perform light sheet on
them and Achieve super resolution
results
the main takeaway here is that once you
have these much larger samples thanks to
the expansion process you now need to
make sure your Imaging field is
sufficiently large so you're not
constantly stitching and tiling
different images together and adding
lots of time onto your experimentation
in image a we can see it takes a typical
CMOS camera 10 Acquisitions to capture
this field
each one of these Acquisitions is in
multiple colors you have overlap between
each image the X Y needs to scan across
the more images you're taking the more
time it's taking the more you're
exposing your sample and the longer your
experiments are taking it's just not
very efficient with the kinetics you
need to take two Acquisitions this
vastly cuts down on the amount of time
taken and allows you to be a lot more
efficient with the speed of the kinetics
also allowing you to run a higher
throughput because you can run this
experiment faster it's a very sensitive
camera so you can often use less light
dose and you can see from the pixel
array that you can still image at a very
high resolution as we see in the
magnified images C and D
so with the kinetics it really helps you
image these very large samples much
faster and much more efficiently
another example of the kinetics being
used for light sheet comes from Dr
Leonardo Ciccone Dr cecconi is Imaging
cleared Mouse Huts so the image here you
can see is a Clarity cleared Mouse Hut
often it would take again a good number
of different Acquisitions in order to
capture a very large sample
but by pairing the kinetics with a
custom 2x telecentric lens you can
capture a field of view like this in the
centimeter range allowing you to get a
whole picture of the heart in just one
acquisition in the whites Square here
you can see an image this is the entire
Mouse heart captured in just one
acquisition
the field of Illumination is very flat
the frame rates are very high and again
this really allows you to up the
efficiency and the throughput of your
experimentation because you can now
capture the heart in just one image
there's no need to scan there's no need
for tiling and again from the magnifying
image you can see this all happens at a
very high resolution so this simplifies
your experiments and it also makes them
more powerful with the kinetics
next we have two custom stories for the
prime BSI Express
this camera is a flexible compact
package with a industry standard 6.5
Micron pixel and a high speed making it
great for light sheet Imaging
our first story comes from Dr James
Madden from the University of Cambridge
who is using multiple prime BSI
expresses for subcellular oblique plane
microscopy this being one of the single
objective formats of light sheet using
the Mr snouty objective that allows you
to look at single cells and highly
sensitive samples at very high speeds
the prime BSI Express performs really
well in this application because it can
image at a very high resolution at a
high speed while maintaining a high
sensitivity thanks to the near perfect
Quantum efficiency and the low noise
modes
this customer story involves the lab of
Professor retifuka
this lab has developed a technique known
as axially swept light sheet microscopy
this technique excels in high resolution
3D imaging of subcellular structures
over large volumes
this is applied in this case to
endothelial cells that form blood
vessels inside zebrafish
with the prime BSI Express and
programmable scan mode
which Phil discussed
you can image using the reader of the
camera synchronized to the scan of the
light sheet and it allows you to really
maximize your Imaging time while
maintaining a really large field of view
at a high resolution again other high
sensitivity
overall the prime BSI Express is a
compact flexible and reliable package
for light sheet microscopy
we also have two examples of the iris 15
due to the very large field of view and
the small pixel the iris is a great fit
for light sheet microscopy this is Dr
Fabian Voigt with miso spin so the Miso
sperm is for miso scale microscopy this
is a very large samples and it's an open
science project aimed at making these
light sheet microscopes for very large
samples as you can probably tell this is
a full Mouse brain again this is cleared
the mouse brain has been captured within
one acquisition on the iris so the large
detector size and the rectangular sensor
of the iris really allow you to capture
a lot in a field of view at a very high
resolution which allows you to capture
fine features especially in a sample as
complex as a brain
and lastly we have Dr Yan hoiskin it
really speaks for itself this is a
cleared zebrafish and you're capturing a
huge amount of it again in one single
acquisition with the rs-15 so the large
chip and the small pixel you can really
optimize this for low magnification
Imaging and now you can image huge
samples like this at very high
resolution again without zooming and
without having to add additional
components onto experimentation
and that just about covers everything we
wanted to talk about today
just to summarize things light sheet is
a highly versatile technique with many
different variations scmos cameras we
present different product lines which
have large sensors and very high speeds
which allow you to make your experiments
higher throughput and more efficient
while also simplifying them different
software components like programmable
scan mode allow you to have advanced
readout control you have the hardware to
do the Imaging but you also have the
software to do more powerful Imaging and
have greater control over it especially
pairing it with the illumination by
pairing the readout of the camera with
the illumination you can further cut
down on the light dose and really run
longer physiological experiments over
the long term without damaging your
samples
and again there's the kinetics
with the kinetics there's just no need
to compromise you get it all you get the
sensitivity the speed the field of view
and the high resolution it's great for
light sheet we also offer the prime BSI
and Iris lines which also perform
extremely well for light sheet and match
the different applications and different
samples that you may want to image
but that's all from us today for this
webinar if you have any questions please
let us know and thank you so much for
attending
thank you Professor kubicek Dr Kumar Dr
koston and Dr Allen for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar with Dr Coast Dunn if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
what software are your cameras
compatible with
thanks Marie uh so the cameras that we
offer and the ones that I spoke about in
the presentation are suitable
for all the software you'd use of major
microscope Company software also a great
deal of Open Source software so we like
to use micromanager and there's other
open source software such as labview
if you want to write your own software
you've quite an advanced custom
application we also offer python
wrappers I'm a compatible with Matlab
and all these other options for really
customizing specific components of the
camera like program or scan mode
for what you'd need to do for your
Imaging these are all available on our
website and if you want to develop them
even further yourself then we have
downloadable development kits and all
sorts for the camera drivers so that you
can match it up to the software that
you'd like to use for your Imaging
great thank you next question what is
the largest sensor camera you offer
so
while we offer
a standard
and 19 millimeter diagonal field of view
which is the 6.5 Micron pixel 2K by 2K
we also have cameras like the kinetics
which go up to 29 millimeter this is the
largest size we offer and we also have
the kinetics 22 which goes up to 22 as
the name suggests because if you're not
going to use an f-mount or a t-mount you
can't access the full 29 millimeters if
you're going to use a c-mount then you
may as well use something that's going
to fit to that size which is the
kinetics 22. if you're not gonna use the
full field of view anyway we can also
offer image Splitters so you can take
the really big frame of something like
the kinetics and split it depending on
wavelength split it depending on focal
plane so you can do simultaneous
multi-plane Imaging or simultaneous
multi-channel Imaging because you can
split the camera sensor up into
different parts and use them that way
thank you
next question do these cameras connect
via SDI or Cam link what protocol do
they use does it connect with the Nvidia
Tegra system
so
the cameras we discussed today
typically have a choice between a USB
which is USB 3.2 Gen 2 so the 10 gigabit
per second version or pcie this pcie
connector allows you to connect it
straight onto the motherboard using a
card and it allow you to have the
maximum data rate you'd need so the
kinetics in its fast mode with the full
frame is as Phil mentioned five
gigabytes per second data rate and you
can do this with the supplied cables
which are all pcie link cables
uh asset protocols we Supply the driver
for all of our cameras which is pvcam
and
this can always be pushed in One
Direction or another so just using a Net
Framework if you'd like it to use
something else or if you'd like your
system to be adaptable with the driver
we have python wrappers for the driver
and we can modify in this way as well
as for the Nvidia Tegra system I'm not
100 sure but I can always get in touch
with engineering and I'll make sure I
can send you a follow-up answer to that
later on
great thank you next question
what are the advantages of different
pixel sizes
so
the kinetics and the BSI Express both
offer a 6.5 Micron pixel and this really
specific size of pixel is designed to
match best for resolution
60x magnification
so it depends on your application if
you're going to look at things that are
very high magnification you can match it
to a very large pixel size but with
light sheets sometimes you want to look
at things that are very low
magnification so you can fit more onto
your field of view this is why something
like the iris 15 has a smaller pixel of
around four microns because this will
match up nicely to 20x or 40x and you
get that combination of low
magnification but high resolution so you
can image these larger samples
great thank you it looks like we have
time for one more question
is it compatible with scanning light
sheet
so yeah there are you do have techniques
the static light sheet
and you will also have techniques like
digital scan or axial scan where the
light sheet is often in motion or either
galvo mirror and this is where you can
really use the CMOS camera rolling
shutter and by synchronizing the readout
of the camera with the rolling of the
beam you can completely minimize any
dark time and this is where things like
program or scan Mode come in you can add
delays to the readout and you can change
the direction of the readout all to
ensure that you match things up with
your beam and eliminate any dark time
all right and it looks it looks like you
can squeeze one more question in which
objectives fulfill the large field of
view of the kinetics camera
so the kinetics goes up to 29 if you
have a microscope that can go up to 25
or more then you can use the objectives
that come with this microscope we in the
lab here we've had success with Nikon
objectives but we also work with Olympus
objectives and Zeiss objectives as well
and you can use these to get a full
field of view image or as large as your
Imaging system will allow with most
crucially a flat illumination as well so
even though it's a large field of view
you can still use these objectives to
illuminate right out to the edges of the
field
great thank you Dr Coast Dunn do you
have any final comments for our audience
I'd just like to say thank you very much
for everyone to attending and
registering if you'd like
any more information on this subject
photometrics.com has all the information
you'd need on the cameras as well as the
techniques if you want to hear more
about light sheets we have a learn
section if you want to hear more about
the kinetics we have product pages and
you can also get in contact with us if
you'd like to ask us any further
questions or inquire about one of our
Solutions
thank you again Dr Coast Dunn Dr kubicek
Dr Kumar and Dr Allen for your time
today in your presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Teledyne photometrics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye